[موسيقى]
مساء الخير
وقال مطروحه على الساحه من سنه
1995 اي منذ صعود الشيخ حمد بن خليفه الى
السلطه وهو والد الشيخ تميم قطر الحالي
السؤال المطروحه على هذا النحو ان عدد من
الدول الكثير من المراقبين
سائر ليه دوله فيها نظام ملكي غير دستوري
يعني غير ديمقراطي شانها في ذلك شان كل
الملكيات اللي موجوده في المنطقه تدعم
ثورات بتسع لتغيير حذف الموضوع لقطر تحرك
على اسقاط نظام هي تتشابه مع
قطر تدعم الجماعات الاسلاميه بكل اطيافها
المعتدل والمتشدد بما يمثل خطوره على
جيرانها من الدول وممكن يمثل خطوره عليها
في المستقبل
ايضا بعد سياستها مربكه الخارجيه يعني
تفتح حلقات جميله جدا مع اسرائيل تدعم
حماس
يكون حليفا للولايات المتحده
وتعزز علاقتها بايران
الحقيقه علشان نفهم سياسات قدر الخارجيه
المدخل من وجهه نظري ليس البحث عن
المتناقضات في السياسه الخارجيه القطريه
ولكن عن الثوابت واهم ثابت في السياسه
الخارجيه القطريه هو تحالفه مع الولايات
المتحده
واي عامل اخر ممكن ان يتغير نحكي الحكام
الاول قدر بلد بالغ الثراء وصغير وكلمه
صغير ليست اهانه ولكنه تعريف علمي يعني
الامم المتحده واساتذه النظم السياسيه
بيسموا الدول
الصغيره و صغيره جدا وغير صغيره وفقا لعده
معايير
عدد السكان الناتج المحلي الاجمالي مساحه
الدوله
يعني من الارض الاخوه وقدر وفقا لاكثر من
معيار دوله صغيره ساحتها اقل من اثناشر
الف كيلومتر مربع وعدد سكانها وفقا
للقرارات الرسميه القطريه في سنه الفين
وعشره نتكلم على حوالي مائتين وخمسين الف
قطري
يعني مقيم وبالتالي هي دوله صغيره في
المساحه وفي السكان ثاني اصغر دوله في
المنطقه بعد البحرين
هذه الدوله الصغيره بالغه الثراء اللي
بتقوم محاوله 13 او 14 في المائه من كل
الاحتياطات المؤكده للغاز الطبيعي في
العالم واقع جغرافيا ما بين البلدين اكبر
منها بكثير وهي السعوديه لم تشارك معها في
حدود الريال وايران اللي تشارك معها في
حدود المائيه وتشارك ايضا معها في حقل
الشمال اللي هو مصدر الاساسيه ولذلك لا
تشعر بالامان لوحدها بين هذين الغارين
الكبيرين الاقوى علشان تشعر بالامان هي
قرارات مثل دول اخرى كثيره صغيره ان
تستعين بصديق او بدوله اخرى اقوى من ايران
واقوى من السعوديه فاستعانت بالولايات
المتحده واقام معها تحالفا قويا بدايه من
عام خمسه وتسعين والى الان
هل التحالف مع الولايات المتحده عمره جديد
على قدر هي منذ
مطلع السبعينات واستقلالها هي مثل باقي
دول الخليج منطقه نفوذ غربي انتقلت من
النفوذ البريطاني الى النفوذ الامريكي
امال ايه اللي جد من بعد سنه خمسه وتسعين
اللي قلت انه قطر في ظل الجديده وقتها
قررت انها بدل ما ان تكون بلد تابع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الحليف الاساسي
للولايات المتحده في المنطقه ان تكون لها
علاقه مباشره بالولايات المتحده ومستقله
على السعوديه قررت هذا القرار عده اسباب
ولا الطموح الشخصي للقيادات اللي كانت
موجوده سواء كان الشيخ حمد
الخليفه الشيخ حمد بن جاسم اللي هما رسم
سياسه قطر منتصره خمسه وتسعين والى الان
في عامل شخص في المساله الامر الثاني هو
عدم ثقتهم او عدم شعورهم بالامان او
بالثقه الكامله في النوايا السعوديه
اتجاههم بسبب بقاء تاريخيه قديمه وخلافات
حدوديه منذ عشرات السنوات انفجرت في بعض
الاحوال او في بعض الاوقات الى صدام مسلح
زي ما حصل في حاله الفساد اثنين وتسعين
خصوصا انه في قناعه لدى القطريين ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لن تسمح بيكر
انها الصغيره ان يقول لها سياسه مستقله
وبالتالي هم دون شهور انه اذا اعتمدوا فقط
على السعوديه لن يكون لهم قدره ابدا على
الاستقلال والتصرف دوله مستقله لكن السبب
الثالث والاهم
طبعا لما اتكلم على السبب الثالث والاهم
العلاقه مع السعوديه
وسياسات قطر الخارجيه في عوامل كثيره
رسمتها لكن يعني يعني تحتاج الى وقت اخر
يعني شيء عوامل تتعلق بالصحه الدوليه
وقتها وانفراد الولايات المتحده من النظام
العالمي الغزو العراقي للكويت اللي اكثر
جدا على طريق التفكير كل دول المنطقه وكل
دوله سعد انهى تؤمن نفسها حتى لا تذكر
معها ماساه الكويت بطريقتها الخاصه لكن
هذه القصه طويله السلم الثالث الاهم علشان
تقدر العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده و تحافظ
على هذا التحالف لا يكفي ان تستضيف
القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه على اربع كما
فعلت قدر لان هذه القواعد كانت موجوده في
السعوديه وانتقلت الى ويمكن ان انتقل الى
اي دوله اخرى في المستقبل
ويمكن ان تظل القواعد العسكريه موجوده في
قدم ولا تضمن
لايات المتحده او تتعهد باستمرار النظام
ودعمه
على شان القطر هذه هذه العلاقه المميزه
لابد ان تثبت للولايات المتحده انها بلد
مفيد وليس عاله على امريكا
وليس
يعني على امريكا عشان تثبت هذا لا بد ان
تتبع مجموعه من السياسات اللي بتؤكد
لامريكا انها دوله مفيده لها وحليف مهم
كل الكلام ده ان هي تكون عندها طموح مستقل
عن السعوديه ان تكون على علاقه قويه متينه
في واشنطن ترجمه كل هذه الاحداث من خلال
سياسات بشكل واضح جدا بعد ثورات الربيع
العربي
بعد ثورات الربيع العربي عام 2011 كانت
قطر الدوله العربيه الوحيده التي دعمت قول
ثورات الربيع العربي تقريبا كلمه تقريبا
دي الوقتي تبليغ كل ثورات الربيع العربي
بسبب السبب الاول ان ان هذه هي سياسه
واشنطن في المنطقه ولم يعد سرا ان واشنطن
دعم جميع
ثورات الربيع العربي تقريبا
تقريبا ايضا وبالتالي كانت قطر الحقيقه ب
تتعاون مع الولايات المتحده في تنفيذ
سياساتها الطموحه في تغيير كامل المنطقه
العربيه ومنطقه الشرق الاوسط والدول
الثلاثه اللي كانوا يتفقوا على هذه
السياسه كانت الولايات المتحده وتركيا
وقطر واحنا تكلمنا على القصه
السبب الثاني لدعم هذه الثورات يتوافق مع
الرؤيه القطريه اللي شايف انه هذا التغيير
فرصه وليس احدى زي ما دول اخرى مثل
السعوديه والامارات شوفوها قدرت شوف هذا
تصورات فرصه وليس التحدي بردو لاسباب يطول
شرحها لكن هي باختصار يرجع الى طبيعه
الجبهه الداخليه في قدر ما عندها مشاكل
عرقيه
مشاكل طائفيه ولا تحديات معارضه سياسيه
قويه ولا فيها مشاكل زي مثلا الوضع في
البحرين وبالتالي شافت ان التغيير لن يضر
ها بل سوف يساعدها انهى
سابقه وتقدر
تزود نفوذها في الدول اللي بيحصل فيها
تغيير بانها تستثمر في القوى الثوريه اهم
عناصر او اهم الكتل الثائره وقتها او
المعارضه الى مستعده للوصول السلطه ما
كانش الشباب الليبرالي ولا العلماني كانت
القوى الاسلاميه والقوى الاسلاميه ايضا
امريكا وتركيا
ومعهم قبل كل شيء فيها البديل الافضل
استماره قطر فيها وهي بذلك تبعات سياسه
توافق سياسه واشنطن اعطيكم اكثر من مثال
مثل لكم على هذا الكلام امريكا دعم كل
ثورات الربيع العربي المعاده في بلد واحد
وهو البحرين ليه البحرين البحرين السعوديه
ذهبت الى اوباما وقالت ان البحرين هي
معطله على كل الفورات الربيعه العربيه لكن
البحرين اللي هي يعني طبعا فيه فنائهم
الخلفي خط احمر وتحت ضغط السعوديه الشديد
جدا اضطر اوباما زي ما قال السفير
والدبلوماسي الامريك المعروف
لي انا شخصيا انه انه يعتبر البحرين
استثناءا من دعم بثورات الربيع العربي
نرجع بالتاريخ شويه كدا 2011 مارس 2011
الشهور التي تلتها تجدوا القطر دعم كل
ثورات الربيع العربي الى دوله واحده وهي
البحريه في هذا البلد اظهرت كاميرات
الجزيره يعني ظهرها لهذه الثورات بل وشركه
قطر في حزب المساعدات كانت حوالي عشره
مليار دولار لدعم النظام البحرين
اعطيك مثال اخر الغرب والشرق تحدث عنه
كثيرا هو بيتكلم على علاقه قطر بعدد من
الجماعات الاسلاميه اللي بعضها مدرك على
قائم الجماعات الارهابيه الولايات المتحده
مثلا
قطر بتعمل كده ازاي ومنها جايه النصف واقع
الامر
السياسه العامه قطر لكل الجماعات
الاسلاميه لم تكن بعيده عن الولايات
المتحده لان الولايات المتحده كانت في
حاجه الى الطرف يقوم بدور القناه الخلفيه
اللي بت تواصل معها الولايات المتحده مع
هذه الجماعات اللي حتى وان عادت ها
الولايات المتحده بتظل في حاجه اليهم
وناخذ مثل الجبهه مصر
جبهه النصره قطر تفاوضت مع اكثر من مره
للافراج عن الرهائن الامريكان وكذلك سواء
في جبهه النصره و القاعده او داعش الافراج
عن راي الامريكان اليابانيين
لبنانيين ومن مختلف الجنسيات لكن الاهم من
كده وتكشف عن الكاتب الامريكي الشهير الا
كنا ليس في الواشنطن بوست وخمسطاشر وده
كشف باحث بريطاني مهم جدا متخصص في شؤون
الخليج اسمه
واظن كان كتاب مقاله مطوله في البي بي سي
وقت 2015 بيقول ان علاقه قطر
بالنصره ما كان في شيء لكن بالتنسيق مع
الولايات المتحده وتركيا والدول الغربيه
لانه المعسكر الغربي وقتها في سوريا كان
يخشى من انضمام
كبيره مصر مع داعش
بيشكلوا تحالف قوي مع بعضهم خصوصا بعدما
اعلنت النصره تحالفها مع داعش وكانوا في
حاجه الى فصل النصره عن داعش بحيث انه لا
يسهل وهم استهداف داعش سهل ماموريتهم في
سوريا خصوصا وان النصره
كانت اهدافها مرحله تتطابق مع الغرب اولا
هي تستهدف اه اسقط بشاره يستهدف اسقاط
بشار هم بطبيعتهم معادين
لايران على اساس طائفي والغرب و معادي
لايران
ايضا هم النصره لا تسعى ل توسيع دائره
استهداف خصوم
سوريا وهذا يخدم المصالح الغربيه تماما
على عكس سياسه الداعش وبيقول ديفيد روبرتس
المقدر تعمل كل هذه الاتصالات مع هذه
الجماعات بعيدا عن المخابرات الغربيه
وبدون موافقتها ما عندهاش هذه الامكانيات
يعني هي بتقوم بدور في اطار التحالف مع
الغرب والولايات المتحده
امثله اخرى كثيره جدا اشهر ما علاقتها ب
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين الولايات المتحده
اعتبرت الاخوان المسلمين منذ اوباما
البديل الجاهز للصعود ان صوت بيكام رؤيه
بعد
اوباما يعني فشل مشروع وخرج السلطه حتى
لما
تغيرت السياسه الامريكيه ولكن ليس 360
درجه بدليل انه حتى هذه اللحظه الولايات
المتحده لم تستطيع ابدا ان تدرك جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين على قوائم الجماعات
الارهابيه وظلت في حاجه للتواصل مع جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين لاسباب كثيره وظلت قطر
بتلعب دور القناه الخلفيه بين هذه
الجماعات المؤثره وبين الغرب وعلى راسها
الولايات المتحده
والمساله لا تقتصر على جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين بل تمتد الى جامعات اخرى اشهرها
مثال طالبان في الوقت الحالي لا انا بتكلم
حضراتكم في امريكا تتفاوض مع طالبان في
الدوحه لايقاف حرب هما معا على الاراضي
الافغانيه
يعني الدور القدره ما زال قائم ومهم حليف
الولايات المتحده يبقى السؤال الاخير
المهم جدا الى تظل
الخلاف بين قدم بينها وبين الرباعي العربي
مصر والامارات والسعوديه والبحرين الحقيقه
من المؤشرات الموجوده كلها لا ت شي بقرب
الحصار هذا الخلاف لان العوامل ادت الى
الخلاف ما زالت قائمه ما فيش اي مؤشرات
على رغبه قطر في التراجع عن سياستها اللي
هي شايف انها بتعزز مصالحها وما فيش اي
رغبه طبعا من الدول المجاوره انها ت تقبل
هذا الدور الاهم والاخطر انه الولايات
المتحده وهي الرقم الصعب في هذه العلاقه
يبدو انها مستفيده مش بس غير المتضرره
مستفيده من هذا الخلاف لانه منطق الولايات
المتحده ان حدث يقام بين حلفاء فهذا جيد
لكن في حاله وجود خلاف لا باس هل ممكن ان
تكون مستفيده من خلال لان هذا الخلاف يؤدي
الى هدم منظمه ال ال ال مجلس التعاون
الخليجي اللي هي اخر ما تبقى من التكتلات
العربيه في المنطقه كل التكتلات المهارات
تبقى مجلس التعاون الخليجي وهذا المجلس
لعب دور المناور للسياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه بعد 2013 المقال وقبل 2013
المقال اه ثوره مضاده على ثورات الربيع
العربي اللي دعمتها امريكا وبالتالي هي
مستفيده من هذا الخلاف لانه يضعف مجلس
التعاون الخليجي ويخليه تعاون شكلي جدا
يبقى الموقف القطري المؤشر تقول او
العلاقه القطريه بها لا يبدو انها سوف
تتحسن في المنظور القريب اشكركم وللحديث
بقيه ان شاء الله